people in a Southwest Valley
neighborhood really concerned after a
load of recyclables was dumped on one of
their streets Madison Kimbrough spoke to
neighbors and joins us near Rancho and
rainbow and Cactus now to explain what
exactly happened there
you would have never known that this
area earlier today was covered in trash
it has since been cleaned up by Republic
Services but neighbors here in the Tela
Rosa Community sharing their
frustrations directly to 8 news now we
didn't know what happened I we thought
there was a crash or somewhere quite the
mess this past weekend in this quiet
Mountain's Edge neighborhood of Tela
Rosa as reports that Republic Services
dumped a large load of recyclables into
the street right outside the
neighborhood making for a messy and
smelly situation people were swerving
cetera Etc it's broken glass everywhere
at the entrance and exit to the
community
I mean I'll get a broom if I have to and
sweep it up myself and the worst part
about it is with the wind and everything
else it's starting to blow through the
neighborhood unfortunately now a few
people have added a few more things to
it there's some wheels and tires that
are sitting there so it's going to
continue to get worse so Republican gets
out here and picks it out
luckily by mid afternoon Monday Republic
Services and Ecotech environmental
started cleaning it up the trash was
gone a short time later the reason for
the spill Republic Services sharing with
me the door to one of their trucks
malfunctioned causing the mess we've
talked to Residents who are just happy
it's all cleared up and that the smell
is almost gone reporting in the
southwest Valley Madison Kimbrough 8
News Now